[Musique]
selon les récits médiévaux des faits or
est élu domicile dans ce lieu situé à la
sortie de poids ni la forêt une histoire
surnaturelle tout droit sorti du
moyen-âge l'oratoire saint fort situé au
coeur de la forêt de rambouillet serait
magique lafontaine d'un mètre 90 aurait
aussi été témoin d'un miracle aux
alentours de l'an 300 l'évêque de
bordeaux traversant la forêt des
yvelines rencontre un enfant
avec une paralysie infirme donc de là il
fait jaillir la source et il se il a
vite l'enfant à se baigner dans cette
eau et l'enfant ressort guéri une eau
miraculeuse fêtée chaque année par les
habitants de poids ni le jour de la
pentecôte les habitants se retrouvent
autour de cet oratoire restaurer au 19e
siècle nous demandons à notre père
robert de venir pour faire une
bénédiction donc il y à un pèlerinage
qui est effectué et nous nous célébrons
ce miracle auprès de la fontaine il ya
auparavant une messe à l'église de
poignet et de l'église
jusque-là fontaine saint fort les gens
viennent à pied poignée vraiment célèbre
par rapport à ça cette fête est aussi
cette centaine une légende vieille de
mille sept cents ans qui n'a pas pris
une ride et qui continue à fasciner des
milliers de visiteurs chaque année